la plus grande découverte en 3000
ans découvrira l'origine d'un
pouvoir secret et conduira les plus grands héros de l'histoire
là où ils ne sont jamais allés avant que vous ne
parliez avec un pharaon embrasse mon personnel
oh ça va si je ne te salue pas et je sais tous les deux
il y a quelque chose de magique dans le
musée La tablette Sun Goes Down commence à
briller et tout prend vie cette
année oui nous nous ressemblons da da non non je
ne suis pas ton Dada pas de contact arrête ça la
magie s'épuise il y a quelque chose qui ne va pas
avec la tablette nous  seront tous morts par
Sunrise hon star hyperventilate hunter
negaduck adieu mais leur plus grande
aventure ces gars dépendent du ravageur qui
vient de commencer nous devons aller à Londres pour
comprendre cela
bonjour bienvenue au British Museum avec qui il
est pourrait être dans un garde de sécurité dans
L'Amérique avec votre arme avec un silencieux
avec vos épées de ninja ce n'est même pas un
peu vrai Je veux que vous voyiez ici
et assurez-vous que personne n'entre ou ne sort
e
Roosevelt Président des États-Unis
d'Amérique Je n'ai aucune idée de ce que cela
signifie ne prends-tu pas une photo et dure
plus longtemps la nuit au Musée secret de la
tombe
nous ne devons jamais parler de ce qui s'est passé
ici aujourd'hui
tu